ladies and gentlemen for the first time
in two days I get to report good news
right before the clothes anyway and I
have no idea how late the tape may be
running the market was up substantially
something like a hundred and thirty
points so perhaps we are surviving black
and blue monday and we have saved as the
closing panel perhaps so what could well
be the most controversial discussion of
the two days we have entitled it as your
program shows the cost of defending us
allies and since the end of World War
two the US has forged very intimate
military ties with its allies in an
effort to preserve world peace though
few of us would ever question these ties
many do indeed question their cost on
today's panel to discuss the expense of
maintaining the present system or two
men who are very familiar with the issue
from two very very different
perspectives political and military as a
member of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee Senator Chris Dodd of
Connecticut plays a crucial role in
developing that chambers impact on US
military policy in formula formulating
his military views senator draws upon
many other experiences but including his
own experience as a reservist in the
Army where he served for six years he
also served in the u.s. Peace Corps for
two years he was first elected to the US
Senate in 1980 he's currently serving
his second term there in addition to a
seat on the Foreign Relations Committee
he chairs the Subcommittee on consumer
affairs and the subcommittee own
children families drugs and alcoholism
stansfield turner has served in a
variety of military functions he began
his career in the US Navy
they're heroes quickly up the ranks
eventually serving as a number of
important commands including commander
in chief of NATO's southern fleet he
also served as head of the CIA under
President Jimmy Carter in between he was
president of the Naval War College at
Newport Rhode Island mr Turner
approaches the the issue of alliances
with the benefit of years of advanced
education he earned master's degrees in
philosophy politics and economics as a
Rhodes Scholar and attended the advanced
management program at the Harvard
Business School will you welcome senator
died and mr Turner thank you very very
much let me at the outset express my
gratitude to the Admiral for allowing me
to go first we're in the process as your
gathered here of voting on the floor of
the Senate in fact on a war powers
resolution dealing with the Persian Gulf
so the topic is timely and and I'm
fearful only that those bells may go off
and I'll be called back to the floor of
the Senate if a vote occurs in the next
few minutes so I'll try and keep my
remarks relatively brief to make the
points I'd like to and then listen to
the Admiral and of time permits
obviously to be around to respond any
questions that you may have first of all
I thank you for that very generous and
kind introduction and let me commend all
of you for being here than these days
particularly must be frustrating I
suppose with all of the action in New
York at these particular moments with
the watching the market and the like but
nonetheless I think most would agree to
some extent foreign policy events
obviously have an impact on market
fluctuations whether or not you can
attribute the events the Persian Gulf to
being a major cause or a minor cause or
any cause at all is open for debate and
discussion but nonetheless certainly as
we live in a ever shrinking world events
which in the past might have taken days
to reach us now we can virtually watch
as they occur I suspect in fact we have
seen instances where military
engagements could be filmed live it's
not uncommon for Israeli pilots during
the brute lebanon conflict to literally
be home by the evening news and watch
themselves in forays over lebanon and
certainly if we know in the last 24 48
hours almost as the events occurred in
the Persian Gulf the secretary defense
was reporting them to the American
people so clearly today we live in a far
more complex a world where information
is readily available to all
instantaneously in an effect has an
impact on decisions I suspect that
things might not have been quite as bad
yesterday in the market were there not
constant information being pumped out
across this country about what was
occurring I suspect that contributed
significantly to the Stampede mentality
that caused the unprecedented action and
the market yesterday but the best
example I guess I can think of to
discuss the question of us commitments
as we close out this century is the
Persian Gulf issue and the debate
surrounding the War Powers Resolution
let me express a couple of comments on
that first of all at a time when most of
international armed conflicts started
with a formal declaration of war our
Constitution assigned as you all know a
right to declare wolf a war solely to
the Congress of the United States during
the 20th century the and especially
after World War two of course the formal
declaration of war gradually disappeared
from the practices of States not only
our own but others around the globe in
the absence of such declaration our
presidents felt increasingly free to
take our armed forces into international
conflicts without the formal consent of
Congress perhaps of course the most
clear example of that presidential
decisions involving the commitment of US
forces was the one fought in Vietnam
while it is true that Congress provided
the money for that conflict and
I would argue strongly escape the
responsibility Congress as you all know
never had a chance if you will or the
opportunity to formally approve or
disapprove the sending of troops to
Vietnam it was dragged along in a way
that was constitutionally ambiguous this
ambiguity and the resulting sense of the
legitimacy substantially I believe
contributed to the national division
resulting from that war that caused such
a tremendous damage to our own self
confidence in the cohesion of our nation
following the end of the Vietnam War
Congress passed the War Powers Act to
restore the original intent or at least
the effort was to restore the original
intent of the Constitution and to be
cognizant of the changing world and the
changing nature of conflict and to
provide for the executive legislative
cooperation without which our nation
would not be able to defend of course
its interests effectively the War Powers
Act is not I would argue an intrusion on
presidential powers it was meant to be a
guarantee that Congress's constitutional
role roll Mayo a role in war making
would be restored over 40 long years we
have had a naval presence in the Persian
Gulf and that is not in dispute our
peaceful presence patrolling the sea
lanes was never questioned by the
Congress and I went to Delhi today it is
not question today either if there were
to be a vote this afternoon on whether
or not the United States ought to be
militarily committed to the Persian Gulf
I would suspect that such a resolution
would pass overwhelmingly in the United
States Senate and I suspect with an
extremely strong vote and the house of
representatives as well unfortunately
there's been confusion over these past
several weeks because of the debate
about the War Powers Resolution and
whether or not it ought to be invoked I
think it's regrettable that we have
ended up bogged down in that debate
because I think it has sent a very
confusing signal not only to our allies
but more importantly to our adversaries
at this particular juncture about
something that is vitally important if a
message is to be heard as effectively as
it could be and that is what I suspect
is the broad-based support across this
country of ours
for the decision to place military
forces in the Gulf to protect and keep
those sea lanes open and free now there
would be I would argue quickly a debate
over whether or not the fleet reef
lagging issue made a great deal of sense
in fact many would look back I think
today and those who supported it and
questioned whether or not that was a
wise decision there were many other ways
of achieving the same result without
going through that gymnastic effort and
maneuver in order to protect those
vessels moving through but on the bottom
line question of whether or not the
United States has an obligation to
commit itself to the free transit of
resources in the Persian Gulf on that
issue that important issue that I think
you would find as I said a moment ago
resounding support now several armed
incidents have taken place since the
stark incident are shooting in capturing
an Iranian mine Lang ship on September
21st the sinking of three gunboats on
october eight and yesterday's
retaliation for the missile attack on
one of the reflagged tankers makes it
abundantly clear i believe that we are
in an armed conflict and the President
cannot legally avoid I happen to believe
compliance with the War Powers Act
anymore for the time being this would
involve the sending of a report to
Congress after which the president would
have 60 to 90 days before Congress could
buy action or inaction mandate the
withdrawal of those forces I frankly do
not understand why the president and his
advisors dread so much the invocation of
the War Powers Act while I and many
members of Congress have had misgivings
as I said about the wisdom of the reef
lagging effort I'm also convinced that
if we had to vote today of course our
presence and the Gulf and even the
continuation of the escort operation
would be confirmed by the Congress I
fail to see how the president imagines
continuing an international conflict for
an extended period without achieving
consensus with the Congress makes sense
it seems to me that he can only be
strengthened by getting Congress's
approval of our military operations our
historic experience shows that Congress
is an extremely reluctant or extremely
rather
reluctant to interfere with presidents
while an armed conflict is impending or
continuing in fact what is pending
before the Senate at this moment under
the condition of cloture is the bird
Warner Amendment which is an alternative
to the straight invocation of the War
Powers Act which considerably eases
those conditions these are the major
differences one we would provide under
bird Warner which passed by the way
longer deadlines than the War Powers
Resolution the substitute targets the
reef lagging escorting operation and not
directly the presence of our forces and
thirdly the substitute requires
congressional action our forces
withdrawal cannot be mandated by
inaction by the Congress that
substantially changes the War Powers
Resolution but nonetheless we think
would involve the Congress at a time
when that kind of involvement could only
be seen or should be seen in a
constructive manner let me emphasize if
I can one of the points I tried to make
here again I think yesterday the
decision to hit targets that were not
armed and caused no loss of life
apparently was the proper response for
the president he could have chosen I
think would have been supported had he
chosen a target of more substance and
more significance but he made the
decision to choose a target that would
send the message without escalating
necessarily the response that we may end
up having from the Iranians but
nonetheless I think it was an
appropriate and proper response where we
do have today that Congress as I believe
we will before the day is out coinciding
agreeing at least on the bottom line
issue the fundamental question I would
think that would also have a profound
impact on Iran and others who might
think or believe because of the Press
report showing a divided nation over war
powers light caused them to reconsider
actions wherein you found the united
states united and together on the basic
proposition of whether or not we ought
to be in the Persian Gulf lastly on the
general proposition of the extent to
which the United States can commit
itself of course we're still bound by
treaties and obligations some of which
were entered into at the end of World
War two at a time when the United States
enjoyed such a
in position militarily in the world that
there was no question about our ability
to respond to conflicts whether they be
in Europe or in South East Asia or at
any other part of the world today of
course that has dramatically changed and
I think it would be an appropriate and
proper time for this president or the
next president to reassess our ability
to live up and to fulfill the military
obligations included in some of those
treaties and to insist if we're going to
maintain them that there be a far
greater degree of reciprocity in some of
those arrangements I don't think it's
conceivable or possible for the United
States today to be involved in as broad
as wide away militarily is it might like
to think it could I think our allies
must recognize this I begin to believe
our adversaries must be sensitive to it
as well I happen to believe that the
kind of conflict we're going to be faced
with as we complete this century and
into the next one will be the kind of
conflict we're seeing in the Persian
Gulf I would suggest that we may find
ourselves in situations in Central
America or the Caribbean or in other
parts of the world where we're going to
need the ability to respond in a highly
mobile fashion very effectively very
quickly to be able to protect harbors to
be able to protect and remove of armed
forces and individuals and it seems to
me we have paid far too little attention
to those needs over the last several
years with far too concentrated
concentration on our ability to win bay
strategic conflict and I think those of
those gaps were made glaringly apparent
when we discovered for instance that we
lacked the kind of mining or of the
anti-mining of ships that were so needed
in the Persian Gulf only a few weeks ago
those gaps I believe will now be made up
but I believe that if we readjusted ease
on some of those levels then we will be
able to maintain our commitments as we
see more of these brush fires of Percy
but at this particular juncture I would
strongly urge that the president take
advantage of this congressional
opportunity to move forward on the War
Powers whether or not anyone likes the
law whether or not you believe its
constitutional or not is certainly a
legitimate debate but the fact of the
matter is it is the law of the land and
it seems to me when presidents I choose
to ignore those
cause then we of course breed the kind
of content contempt and division within
our society the lack of cohesion which
is absolutely necessary to have a
cohesive and effective foreign policy
and I thank you for listen good
afternoon in looking at the question of
the costs of Defense of any of the
countries from which you come I think we
have to be careful that we don't focus
only on the issue of the dollar costs a
dollar costs and how we divide them
between ourselves and our allies are
really a purely political issue there's
no way you can set a standard either in
accordance with what the United States
is paid in the past in accordance with
percentages of gross national product or
any other kind of yardstick it's a
purely political issue and I would
suggest to you from overseas that the
politics of the United States are such
that the public is becoming weary of the
costs of defending our allies in a joint
defense effort and public is going to
call for a reduction in those costs in
time ahead but what I'd like to do when
picking up where senator Dodd made some
references at the end of his talk is to
point out that there are other costs
that are even more important to the
United States and to our friends and
allies than the dollar costs of Defense
of the Allied territories these are the
costs in terms of the impact on American
military readiness our participer tissy
paiting in joint defense efforts for
instance preparations for the joint
defense of Europe have so dominated
American military thinking over the past
forty two years since World
or to that our military has been less
than ready for other forms of combat the
proof of this lies in the fact that we
have had less than acceptable
performance from our military in almost
every instance of actual combat
employment since World War two we fought
to a tie in Korea we lost in Vietnam we
failed miserably on the deserts of Iran
we won in little Grenada but with
greater loss of life and more confusion
and was warranted now if I sound unduly
critical above the American military
performance let me assure you that it
hurts me to do that because I'm a
military professional than in part
responsible for this but you as people
from the business world are accustomed
to watching the bottom line the bottom
line for any military establishment is
victory on the battlefield and the
United States military has not had a
record since world war two of consistent
victories there are many people to blame
some inside the military and some
without but I think a major contributing
factor has been that our political
leaders and our military men have given
inordinate attention to the defense of
our allies and most particularly our
Western European allies now in preparing
for defense of Western Europe we think
about large-scale combat against a
highly sophisticated and capable enemy
we think in terms of a particular type
of terrain and we think of having the
benefit of pre-positioned troops and
equipment now in this kind of
circumstance for instance large tanks
heavy artillery are perfectly fine even
though they're very difficult to
transport to even more remote areas of
the world and difficult to maneuver in
terrain like jungles now it's no wonder
then I believe with this emphasis on
heavy tanks and artillery and the
analogous forces and the other services
that we stumbled in the jungles of
Vietnam no wonder that we did not have
the training or the right kind of
helicopters to deal with a small-scale
stealthy rescue operation in Iran I
believe the United States today needs to
de-emphasize our role in the defense of
Europe when we talk about doing our
military planning in our military
procurement and we must be ready for the
more likely contingencies in other parts
of the world for instance a tank that is
eighty percent optimum for Europe but
also eighty percent optimum for being
transported to remote areas would be
preferable for us to build instead of
the ones we're building today which can
only fit into our largest transport
aircraft by ones or maybe tues in short
i believe the United States needs and
will be looking for in the years just
ahead a more balanced outlook in our
military planning now a second problem
which arises from our focus on the
defense of Europe South Korea and Japan
is a false dependence on nuclear weapons
42 years ago the United States had a
monopoly on nuclear weapons at that time
it made eminent sense for us to threaten
the devastation of the Soviet homeland
if the Soviets were to invade any one of
our allies it was conveniently a very
cheap form of
defense but when in the 1950s the
Soviets gained a capability to retaliate
with nuclear weapons against the
American homeland it was no longer a
satisfactory strategy for the United
States it became a charade something
that we would not ever really do now
while I hope we would not hesitate to
respond in kind if the Soviets should
attack American soil with nuclear
weapons I do not believe an American
president would launch nuclear weapons
in the defense of Western Europe South
Korea or Japan put yourself in his shoes
whether we launched those weapons from
Omaha or from the weapons we've placed
in Europe and the Far East we would have
to anticipate a response against
American territory if the detonation
were on Soviet soil the response would
be on American soil we would be trading
Washington for Moscow in the defense of
bond or soul or Tokyo for a president
the near certainty of some substantial
nuclear devastation in our own country
whether of Washington or some other city
without way even the loss of Western
Europe to a Soviet invasion the reason
for that is that there is still or there
would be still some hope a recovering
from the loss of Western Europe but
there would be no recovery from the
nuclear devastation of Washington or
other cities and in addition there would
be the danger facing any president who
initiated the use of nuclear weapons
that it would spread into a worldwide
Holocaust and I believe that that kind
of danger would clinch a president's
decision against initiating the use of
nuclear weapons now in the 1960s we
realized that this was the situation
that this nuclear strategy for the
defense of allies was not sound but we
hated to admit we avoided admitting it
for fear that our allies would not
afford the cost of the necessary
conventional forces to deter invasion by
communist forces instead the United
States gradually built up a store of
shorter range nuclear weapons in Western
Europe and in the Far East and we
profess the policy that if there were an
invasion of any of our allies we would
respond with those weapons against those
immediate forces whether they were in
eastern Germany or North Korea or
wherever that was very logical but the
result of this has been an illogical
widely differing interpretation of what
we have termed the American nuclear
umbrella our allies in Europe believe
there's a nuclear umbrella over both
eastern and western Europe and in Korea
and Japan they believe there's a nuclear
umbrella over that and the Allies look
on this umbrella in the following terms
that if inside the umbrella there is a
conventional war and our allies are
losing the United States will launch
nuclear weapons outside that umbrella
over that umbrella to Moscow now they
think too that while there may be some
nuclear weapons coming back but they'll
all land in the United States and the
nuclear destruction will all be outside
this on brother but since the 60s the
American view of the nuclear umbrella is
that if there's a war inside one of
these umbrellas and our allies are
losing will launch these short-range
tactical nuclear weapons all inside the
umbrella and all the nuclear destruction
will be contained therein now the recent
negotiations for an intermediate-range
nuclear weapons treaty with the Soviet
Union have brought all this
inconsistency out into the open our
European
allies for instance can see very clearly
that if we're not willing to launch
weapons at the Soviet Union from the
United States and we then take all of
the shorter nuclear weapons that could
hit the Soviet Union from their
territory and dispense with them there's
only one prospect left and that's this
nuclear battle with short short range
weapons inside the umbrella and that
looks to our allies quite understandably
as though it's self-defense by mutual
nuclear suicide in my view it's only a
matter of time until our allies realize
that this is not a suitable defense
strategy for them and yet the greatest
danger of this myth of nuclear defense
of our allies is that the more we in the
United States talk about this form of
Defense the more likely it is in a
period of tension and crisis that we may
have nuclear war by miscalculation or
mistake and so in sum I would leave you
with a couple of thoughts please the
first is that the United States needs to
move away from its focus of defense on a
defence of its allies and be more
prepared to defend allied and American
interest in other areas of the world as
we are today in the Persian Gulf and
secondly but the increased risks of
nuclear war that come from this myth of
reliance on nuclear weapons to
counterbalance communist conventional
power is just not worth it thank you